hello everyone and welcome to the fourth
episode of chess sorcery the game was
played in 1968 in vinkovci that's in
Croatia it was played between Mario Beth
took Croatian international master and
Emily college and well it was it was a
very strong tournament it featured 14
players that we've got 8th place in the
end but well that's not a bad result
considering for example Samuel Reshevsky
was 6th in this tournament and the
tournament was won by Bobby Fischer
himself with a result of 9 wins 0 losses
and 4 draws second place was last in
heart and third was Milan Mutulu which
interesting 9 wins 0 losses and 4 draws
is the exact same result Karpov head in
1994 linearis tournament and although
Fischer definitely crushed the field and
well his games were classic Fischer
games you know he just wins but this
game caught the most attention in the
tournament better cover system to lodge
so let's see the game better has the
white pieces and we have d4 Knight to f6
c4 g6 Knight to c3 and b5 the groom fell
defense Knight to f3 Bishop to g7 and
now [ __ ] Queen to a4 with check the
floor variation and now Knight to c6 is
a bit more standard here but Nikolas
goes for Bishop to d7 would attempt on
the Queen and ok
White was a temple but he plays Queen to
b3 and now gaining a tempo as this pawn
is not unprotected on b7 we have D
captures on c4 and Queen captures on c4
white doesn't capture this pawn and b7
as this wouldn't really this wouldn't
really do anything for white you can't
really go for the rook or anything black
has a pretty good option of going for a
knight Knight to c6 and this is
perfectly fine for black like this even
better here
so after this D captures and C for
better play Queen captures and c4 and
nickel which castled we have E for and
well although I did play a lot of moves
with this Queen the Queen is pretty okay
here on c4 it's not that easy for black
to kick her way from from such a nice
square but we have a knife to a 6 e 5
attacking this knight on f6 and here
nickel which gets the idea that he will
play Bishop to e6 now to kick the Queen
away from from c4 and here
well the engines idea is probably Queen
to a4 maybe Queen to e2 but well if if a
queen to a4 move or queen to be to move
or played this game wouldn't be getting
the attention it gets so many years
after it was played in this position a
better place it captures and f6 so very
nice Queen sacrifice I mean you are
getting three pieces for the Queen but
still it's it's completely unnecessary
to do this Bishop captures Queen and c4
as you don't really have any other
options if you don't capture the Queen
you're just down a piece we had F
captures on g7 now threatening to
capture the rook
so King characters on g7 and Bishop
captures on c4 and okay you have three
pieces for the Queen but what doesn't
really have anything exact here I mean
there's no clear win or nor is white
even better here we have Knights to be
for going for a night to see to check
for King the king and the rook Bishop to
b3 protecting c2 and we have c5 and
black is playing okay here this is like
it's still better here and white still
has to prove that his Queen sacrifice is
is worthy D captures on c5 and here a
backpack allows this night to d3 trick
we have King to e2 and knife captures
and c5 and rook to d1 and so far both
players are playing pretty much the best
moves in the position Queen to a5 we
have Bishop to c2 as well now the threat
was knife capture zombie 3 winning this
rook
so Bishop the c2 and we have Queen to a6
probably a better move would be to
activate the rook for example rook a to
d8 but okay we have Queen to a6 which
check King to e1 and our rook a to ca
so probably located here it was a better
idea but black probably wants to play
rook F to d8 so that's why this works
place to see it
we have Bishop to e3 now and well with
this Bishop please remove or white white
at least equalized the position we have
Queen to e6 now and we have rook to defy
white is what is really trying trying to
achieve something he's going for rook
881 he wants to double up double up on
the D file and well here black played b6
probably probably the better move was
something like rook F to d8 you know to
to confront white on the D file but okay
we have b6 and now rook a to d1 okay
what and now white one the D file will
Queen to g4 attacking the G to pawn king
f1 and we have Queen to b4 now attacking
the B to Point Bishop the c1 Queen to c4
would check King to g1 and we have twin
to a6 black doesn't really have a have a
plan here he does have a queen but it's
it's not that easy to come up with a
plan this the both of these rooks and
the D file are really strong both
bishops are eyeing that King and g7 and
both white knights are well not ideally
placed but but they're placed nicely and
here we have h4 White has a lot of
pieces so he wants to go for the attack
h5 not long and white to push h5 himself
bishop back to e3 Queen to b7 and we
have Knight to g5 we have a six and we
have night ct4 and here Nicholas gets an
idea it's sort of a tactic he plays
Knight to d3 and well if either of these
rooks captures the knight and III then
rook captures on c2 and well if Bishop
captures night then Queen captures rook
on d5 so instead of all of this after
night to d3 that book simple plays
Bishop to b3
pretty much well this is an improved
version of the bishop when he was in
situ because not desiring that f7 square
Knight goes back to b4 as it's now
really attacked so now he's attacking
this rook and on d5
but now the tactics are in Mario's favor
as he plays rook to d7 I would have an
attack on the Queen and the e7 pawn
we have rocked the c7 and now comes rope
captures on c7 Queen captures on c7 and
now the idea behind all of this Bishop
captures on f7 and it's actually in this
position that Emily Coolidge resigned
the game I don't know the exact timers
the exact times on the clock but this is
completely reasonable regardless of the
time on the clock because what's the
idea well of course if rook captures
Bishop you get Knights to e6 check for
King the king and the Queen and c7 white
is up too much material if you don't
capture the bishop
well why this still threatening knight
c6 forking pretty much everything so if
you play something like for example
sorry not that but if you play something
like Queen to c8 getting the Queen out
of the pin well
Bishop to b3 and black is without a move
White is still threatening nice to e6 14
the king and the rook and if you try to
try to prevent this for example if you
try to move the King for example King to
h8 you get Bishop to d4 check and after
you stop this as the King has nowhere to
go
rook to f6 simply capture the rook and
the knight cannot be captured if the he
captures neither on f6 then Bishop
captures on f6 wood checkmate and if you
don't play King to h8 if you try
something like for example rook rook to
e8 this is also completely crushing nice
to e6 with check King to g8 and now
Knight to g5 locking all the squares
around the black king and after black
makes any move it doesn't really matter
what move for example b5
you get
tonight to see seven check from the
bishop on b3 King to g7 you captured
rook Queen captures and now rook to d8 a
beautiful finishing move
because if Queen captures rook on dat
you get night to e6 again with the Royal
fork for King the king and the Queen and
if you don't capture the rook the Queen
doesn't really have anywhere to go if
you can go to a seven I can't go to the
eight the only square you can go to is
Queen to c6 and now you get this
beautiful Bishop to b4 with with with a
certain checkmate to come you can't
block it with e5 the simply prolongs the
inevitable Queen f6 loses the Queen and
while only other move you have available
is King to h6 and this losses to rook to
e8 rook to e8 with checkmate so yeah
definitely definitely a game worthy of
showing after Bishop captures on f7
Emily Coolidge resigned the game and
well a lot of years have passed since
this game was played and well even it
was a tournament that Bobby Fischer
participated in and won without losing a
single game so it's it's really nice
that this is this is one of the more
famous games from that tournament so
yeah that's the game this is chess
sorcery episode 4 I do hope you enjoyed
it as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon